- I see you, Jessi, the internet is full
of stories that will make you smile.
Y'all and I pick my favorite
and present them here.
This is what I'm liking.
When Janita was eight
she promised her grandmother
who she lovingly calls Momo
that one day she would
buy her a house for years.
Momo lived in a tiny apartment in Portland,
Oregon helping raise her
more than 20 grandchildren.
I'm like woo.
And year after year Janita never wavered.
She kept reminding her
grandmother about the promise.
Finally, after 23 years and
with the whole family
present Janita made good
on her pledge, we have Janita and Irma
better known as Momo dialed in.
They watch in Portland.
KPT V is what they watch on.
What's up ladies?
(crowd cheers)
- Hi. How are you?
- Y'all are both so beautiful.
I'm gonna lead with that
first off and, and Janita.
Like why was it so important
to you to keep that promise?
- It was important for
me to keep that promise.
Not only to me, but to my whole family.
We are a village.
This is our rock.
And her story.
Mama was pushed in the, a dark room saying
that she was gonna pass away
and she just asked God to keep her
so she can take care of her children.
And so not only did she do
that, she raised her children
and help raise her children's children.
So she kept good on her promise.
And I wanted to keep good on my promise.
I mean, I kept having dreams
and visions about getting
her home and it happened.
So I tried to put a plan in place.
I tried to get her home
in 2020, but COVID kind
of slowed things down, but
2021, I made it happen.
- Oh my gosh.
That's amazing.
And Irma, what do you think of the house?
- I love
You've gotta love all
those grand babies too.
That's amazing.
Well, thank you guys
so much for joining us.
I love this story.
It's so beautiful.
It started out when you were
just little and it ended up
you know
actually happening and coming
to fruition in the end.
Super cool story.
Thank you for sharing with us ladies.
I'm liking your post right now.
- Thank you
- All right.
And that's not all our season
long partner, Pilot Pen makers
of friction.
The go to erasable pen of
"The Kelly Clarkson Show".
Want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly and just
doing amazing things like.
you ma'am.
So they're gonna give
you a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(crowd cheers)
- Amazing. Thank you.
- Thank you
- Oh my god
Your eyes popped open and then
cocked to the side your head.
That was amazing.
Thank you so much, ladies.
Y'all have a blessed day.